in today's video I'm going to show you
exactly how to create this stunning
Villa using Autodesk Revit now if you're
thinking why Autodesk well I saw this
video a couple weeks ago and I was
inspired I really loved how they've
designed around the landscape and how
they utilize the secluded space to make
the perfect home so I started thinking
if I could do the same no limitations no
restrictions what would it be and how
would I do it I started sketching an
idea up and it was a secluded private
Villa cut into the side of a mountain
completely consumed and immersed by
Nature obviously overlooking the
beautiful water and the islands in front
of me today's video is sponsored by
Autodesk because I wanted to partner
with a company that is changing how the
world is designed and made Autodesk
technology spans architecture
engineering construction product design
manufacturing media and even
entertainment they Empower innovators
like myself to solve challenges
regardless of how big or small with
Autodesk you have a wide variety of
software choices all of which are are
there to design and make a better world
for all of us that's why today I'm using
Autodesk Revit to create the best
possible Villa now let's turn around to
this screen and get started with today's
tutorial first of all let's start with
the elephant in the room how am I using
Revit on a Mac well I simply downloaded
parallels and installed Revit Windows 11
came straight away with parallels and it
was a very very simple and easy download
process for this video specifically I'm
going to focus on the architectural
design and the design process of how
this Vision could actually become a 3D
reality Autodesk has been a global
leader in 3D design for so long and all
of our engineers and Consultants are
always using Revit so for me personally
it's more so about understanding Revit
understanding how my consultants and
Engineers work to be able to better
myself as an architect so that's why
this challenge today exists and is so
critical we're going to start today's
video by going into new Revit file and
we're going to select a metric
architectural template for me it's
metric because I'm an Australian there
for you it can be Imperial it's
completely up to you guys next we're
simply going to dive in and press OK
find ourselves immersed in the Revit
environment and the first thing I'm
going to do is jump across to one of my
elevations to adjust my story settings
as quickly and as easily as I can for
this design we're going to use level one
as our ground floor plan so what I'm
going to do is double click on level one
and type in ground floor press enter and
then go ok to rename all corresponding
I'm going to go ahead and change level 2
to roof and press OK once again next I'm
going to highlight my ground floor level
press command or control C press the V
button and I'm going to drop that down
1.8 meters pressing okay this for me
level three is going to be our pull now
you can see we're already starting to
formulate that idea that we've already
created and showcased the best thing
about this is I actually have no idea
what that picture looks like that I
showed you at the start of this video
we're both going to find out together
throughout this video now that I've
created my pool I can see it's still
black and doesn't show up here on my
left hand browser panel so I'm going to
come up top hit view go to view plans
tap floor plan and introduce pull into
our plans and there we go we can see
Paul has dropped in on the left hand
side it's also automatically created a
tab at the top what I'm going to do is
go back to my ground floor plan and work
my way from the top down so let's start
by going up the top to our architectural
tab where we're going to find all of our
elements we're going to jump into wall
first of all and we're going to select
the type of wall structure we want to
use because we're cutting this into the
ground it's most likely going to be a
300 millimeter concrete wall or
something quite substantial let's start
anywhere in this project click once and
we'll see our Dimensions appear I really
miss this feature and it's something
that I truly love about Revit so we can
just go ahead and type in nine meters
press enter go up by holding shift type
in 4 meters and finish off our box so
now we have this one box that I'd like
actually to be four meters internally
and 9 meters into internally both ways
so by simply clicking on either of these
external walls I can get these
dimensions and quickly and rapidly
adjust which makes life so simple now I
want another one of these blocks across
on the right hand side I want to split
the design into two parts so let's go
ahead and highlight those four walls
control command C control command V and
let's shift that across so we keep three
meters in between by simply clicking and
dragging without actually doing any
mathematics I don't know what that
Dimension is but by coming up to the top
here to our move tool I can select one
of the corners come to another corner
and miraculously I've actually managed
to get it at three meters perfect so we
can leave that right there where it is
and move on to the next part of our
design if we come back up to
architecture at the top hit our stairs
we can start designing a beautiful
staircase that leads us in to this
design so let's simply draw three steps
leave a gap and then draw the remainder
of our Rises the stairs are
automatically generated based on your
story levels so you don't have to worry
about how many steps or anything that
needs to happen now that staircase has
been created all we have to do is come
up top hit the Finish edit button mode
and our staircase is automatically
generated I don't really want the
handrails so I'm going to select both of
them and press delete I'm now going to
select downstairs and move them I want
the third step to align with the edge of
our concrete and at the same time I want
it to be that full length so because
we've already finished editing that
let's double click it select one of the
stairs and simply drag it out until it
snaps to the edge we want to do the same
with the bottom stairs so we create a
beautiful set of three metal white
stairs press that ok button zoom out a
little bit if you're enjoying this video
so far make sure you check out the first
link in the description box for free
30-day trial of Autodesk Revit if you're
loving the tutorial you're going to be
able to spend some more time on this
exact design and slowly progress your
skills in Revit and now let's check out
what we've done in 3D already if we come
up to the top you're going to see our
default 3D View and holding shift with
our scroll wheel we can scroll around to
see what we've created Revit by default
will show you this black and white line
feature if you come down to the bottom
you're going to see the visual Styles if
we click on that and just go constant
colors for Simplicity we're going to see
something come to life now this appears
like a Timber staircase to me so I'm
going to select that staircase and
change the actual type so let's say I
want to pre-cast staircase click it once
it will automatically change it for me
what we can infer from this 3D model so
far is a simple fact these walls are way
too low so let's hold the control button
select all of our walls and then jump
across to our properties menu on the top
left hand side change our top constraint
from unconnected all the way up to our
roof so we press once press escape and
automatically our walls shift to the top
of our roof structure if we decided to
go into our elevations change the height
of this roof it will automatically
change all those walls with it which is
amazing so let's undo that and keep
working on our ground floor plan now for
me I'm thinking the entry into these two
pods this is going to be my living and
this is going to be my sleeping quarters
is going to have to be through this
section here so let's double click on
our stairs once again let's activate
this landing and increase the size ever
so slightly personally I want it to be
as large as I can make it so let's say
two and a half meters pushing our stairs
all the way back the next challenge that
we're going to face is the simple fact
this staircase is not aligned with the
bottom level of our floor so let's jump
into our East Elevation let's highlight
all of these walls and double tap HH to
automatically and rapidly hide those
walls all I have to do now is Select my
staircase and offset the base by minus
521 and now we can see that the base of
our Landing is perfectly level with our
ground floor coming down to the bottom
to these cool little sunglass looking
icon hit that reset temporary hide and
everything will come back to life now
let's jump back to our ground floor plan
and start modeling the rest to this
building if we come into architecture
and we go to our floor structure what we
want to do is actually create a couple
stepping stones in to the water so for
me personally I'm seeing this swimming
pool wrap around out the front and
create something stunning so that's
going to be the end of our staircase I'm
going to make it at least a meter deep
and I'm going to move that to the edge
now if I press OK come back into 3D
you'll see that we've created our first
landing again not offset correctly so
that's again minus 521 offset that
landing and it's beautifully presented
jumping back into our ground floor plan
let's copy and paste this one or two
more times just so we can get something
special happening now that we've copied
two more stairs let's select our level
Landing double click it to reactivate
and now let's make it significantly
bigger so we can actually create a
beautiful Landing let's select one of
these sides and double click so we can
adjust this to six meters then we want
to select the opposite side so we can
adjust the depth let's make that 1500
just enough for saving space and then
Center align it to our other stepping
stone and push it out 200 mil pressing
OK escape and jumping back into our 3D
we're starting to model more and more
and making this come to life so now
let's jump back into our floor plan and
make this pool with a nice curved front
natural organic Edge if we double click
on our pool plan we're going to see a
couple elements pop up and that's okay
instead we're going to come to our left
hand panel up the top scroll down to our
under layer and select ground floor now
that we have our ground floor underlaid
so we can see what's going on personally
I think there's one too many Stepping
Stones so let's delete one of those
Stepping Stones select all of these and
then push it back to create that Landing
otherwise that pool is just going to be
way too big and completely out of
proportion now I want to come up to the
annotate tab up top and go to my detail
line I want to grab my spline tool and
all I want to do really is draw an
organic little curve running all the way
across the front of that pool this is
going to give me a good reference of
what what my actual pool is going to
look like and a very easy method of
following along with my wall so now we
can jump back up to architecture go to
the wall select our 300 millimeter
concrete make sure our base is at pool
make sure our unconnected top height is
at 1800 and simply start following this
wall now we're going to move on to using
the arc tool which is going to allow us
to create basically a pool Edge that
doesn't look too unrealistic and
dissimilar to this curve now I don't
want to copy this curve perfectly
because I want these actual concrete
panels to be able to follow an organic
form and to actually look like they
would work in real life so as I'm
clicking through this spline tool I'm
making sure that I'm following along and
still taking very keen notes of how that
wall actually connects and looks like in
real life I can delete that spline
because I don't need it anymore then I
can finish it off by pressing TR for
trim selecting the inside of my wall
selecting my other wall and
automatically trimming that away
pressing escape jumping back in to 3D to
see what we've created we're coming
closer to our actual final product so
now we see our pool structure created
and the back missing let's jump back
into pool come back into our wall simply
finish off the base of that wall and
come back into 3D what we're going to
notice is that our stairs are again a
little bit too low and not really
working for us so we're going to hold
the control button select our curved
walls we Simply Now want to reduce the
height by five two one to actually
reduce it to the height of that step
there if we wanted to increase the depth
of the pool we could but for now it's
simply just going to be a very shallow
lat pull now we see these walls jutting
out just a little bit too far for my
liking and not really aligning to the
top that wall so now I'm going to select
one of these walls and go edit profile
this allows me to edit the profile of
this wall really really quickly what
we're going to do in this edit pane is
select the external line drag that to
the top of our wall make sure it is
perfectly aligned there select the Top
Line drag that to the corner of that
wall remove these constraints that we've
just created and introduce one more
segment to finish off the top now let's
press OK see what we've created there we
go we've linked that top of wall back in
perfectly we'll repeat the same step on
the other side and come back now we have
our pool coming together which means we
need to work on our roof and our actual
architectural design overall let's jump
back into our roof plan and make sure
our ground floor plan is still undelayed
what we want to do is come back into
architecture and because we're going to
be growing a garden over the top we want
to actually use a floor instead of a
ceiling so let's come to our floor tool
let's go to a 300 mil generic concrete
slab so it can actually maintain the
weight of that roof select our outline
box tool and draw a nice big rectangle
now I do want this rectangle to float
out at least another 1200 so let's pump
that out to six meters press OK I have
this vision of the Landscaping creeping
between the building and the roof
structure it's self so I'm going to
select another rectangle box and I'm
just simply going to draw a small little
rectangle roughly here to allow those
plants to creep through the concrete and
over the facade of the building I also
don't need this concrete roof over the
edge of the stairs so I'm going to cut
that concrete roof back and then remove
the center line so there is no concrete
above I also want to do over the main
entries so I'm going to create a couple
of these boxes select them copy paste
and just drag a couple in the middle of
that section now I can go ahead and
press the Finish button then jump back
into 3D to see what we've created so
what we've created is this beautiful
roof structure with our walls connected
a little bit too high because our walls
are connected directly to our roof
structure and we haven't created a
ceiling level that's what's causing this
issue here so if I jump back into East I
can simply select copy paste move 300
millimeters down and call this my
ceiling level and then readjust my top
constraint from roof to ceiling
and there we go automatically it is
adjusted all those walls down we see
that plant slit right at the front we
see the beautiful Shadow play coming
through in the main staircase and our
building is starting to take some shape
and some form obviously we need a
planter box on top of our roof to
actually support these plants so let's
jump back into our roof plan and
reselect something so for this I'm
probably just simply going to use some
block work let's go 140 masonry now what
we're going to do is simply draw our
planter box on top of our wall and
ideally create this center cut out
around our centerpiece jumping back into
3D those walls are way too high
selecting them all we don't want them
constrained we don't need them going up
to eight meters let's say they only need
to be 700 millimeters to get some nice
clean fill in there and so that we can
actually get some plants to grow now in
my head we're going to see these
beautiful plants Cascade through the
slit down the glass and over the facade
both of my sides on my left and right
are going to be completely covered by
the natural landscape jump back into our
ground floor plan and start actually
mapping out the insides here now I won't
go into too much detail of what I
imagine the inside to look like but if
it was me I'd be designing it very
simply I'd have two walls on either side
with a walk-in robe straight down the
middle and I have my bathroom with a
separate toilet on the left on the right
hand part I'd obviously have some sort
of living room smack bang in the middle
a beautiful feature fireplace separating
my living room and my dining room then
I'd have my kitchen up the front and I'd
have some form of scullery and laundry
at the rear now it's probably time to
move on it's time to actually think
about how this interacts with the
outside world for me personally no
limitations no restrictions just using
all of our imagination creativity
without even thinking about regulations
what I'd love to see here is one
beautiful sliding panel door system so
it would go all the way across nine
meters wide four meters tall both spaces
now there is no default door like this
or default sliding window that this in
Revit so what I've gone ahead and done
is downloaded a Revit family from AWS
windows so simply file open and open a
new family will allow you to import any
of your grabit families and then
directly import them into your project
once they're imported you come back up
to architecture go to the door or window
whichever one it was actually imported
as and select the window or door that
you've imported for me it's this AWS 702
slide Master which is so convenient
because I don't have to model it select
it and go edit type I'm not really
worried about the settings or anything
up the top I just want to increase this
door to the maximum width what I need it
for so the overall height 2-1 is going
to change to 4 meters the width is going
to change to 9 meters and then I'm going
to press OK we have the entire center of
our living space completely pushed open
I'm going to do the exact same thing on
the other side so these two spaces now
need to interconnect between each other
and obviously we need a nice beautiful
front door so let's come back into our
architecture go to our door and let's
use something default from Revit we're
going to use this m single flush door
I'm going to drag and drop that one
right there and I'm going to do the same
thing over here on this side I don't
like the way this door swings so if I
select this door I can either hit some
of these arrows here or hit the space
button to automatically flip those doors
across what I also don't like is the
style of the door so what we're going to
do is hit edit and the first thing we're
going to change is this door material so
let's change that door material and
let's make that glass missing okay and
then scrolling down to our Dimensions I
want this door to be grand I want it to
be beautiful and I want it to most
likely be extremely expensive so what
I'm going to do is create a custom door
that door's height is going to be three
seven which is the actual height of our
ceiling and it's going to be at least
1500 wide I'm going to press OK let that
update and then adjust our doors so they
actually fit into our space coming back
into 3D you'll see these doors are
obnoxiously tall but that's exactly how
I want them to be I want them to be
grand I want them to be luxurious before
we finish this project off there's only
a couple things left to do one we need
to model our terrain and two we need to
change some of these materials so let's
start with the fun stuff let's change
some of these materials if we come up to
the top to our modify tab you're going
to see this paint tool now this is the
easiest way and the quickest way for me
to just quickly paint everything that I
see in this space let's start by typing
in concrete I want this block work to
actually be concrete cast and situ I
don't mind what the inside of the
brickwork looks like because well it's
going to be covered in Earth anyway so
nobody's going to see it I then also
want the edge of my concrete that's
exposed to be matching this concrete
wall I don't mind what the top looks
like because you're never going to see
it from the ground below and it's going
to be covered mostly in Plants anyway I
want to be able to actually change this
material in Twin motion or any rendering
software now I understand I'm using a
ceiling tile in this instance because I
don't want to crack a new material I
simply want to be able to use that space
of this design for a different material
in a 3D rendering software now that
we've added a couple textures to this
project and it's going to allow us to
freely adjust as we see fit in an actual
rendering software we can go ahead and
model our topography our Topography is
going to be a little bit challenging
here so we're going to have to work with
it as we model this topography because
it isn't a real project it is a figment
of my imagination I have no idea what
the topography needs to be but I know it
needs to work to this design so let's
double click on our site plan to see
what's going on below us I want to jump
into massing insight and I want to
select topography there is a number of
ways to do this but I'm just going to
show you the quickest and easiest way
for me personally what we're going to do
is start by placing two points left and
right either side miles away then we're
going to slowly work our way around this
building selecting key points where we
want to be able to adjust the levels
just right so for me that means all
around this pool at critical
intersection points and around the
facade as well once we've gone ahead and
added a few too many points that we're
going to like to adjust we're going to
finalize by dropping two more points on
either side left and right and pressing
ok
jumping back into 3D we're going to see
we've created basically a flat box that
has nothing to do with what we've
actually just drawn but that's because
we haven't edited any of those hot spots
that we created if we select our surface
and then go edit we can actually start
adjusting some of the hotspots so these
Hotspots for example need to be lifted
to the top of this stair I can easily
measure these here understand that's
three one three oh point four and
highlight those two hotspots and adjust
their elevation on the left hand side to
three one three oh point four what
you'll see is an automatic adjustment of
Aaron's higher topography which is an
incredible feature that makes life so
simple the two end hotspots I want even
higher to make sure that ground is
falling further towards us so let's type
in five meters and continue to see our
sight fall exactly where we want it the
hot spots in the corners where our
ground is actually going to connect to
our roof I do genuinely want that to go
to the full 4.7 meters so that ground
interacts and naturally slopes all the
way past our actual Roof Garden which if
I go back to the site the floor plan now
it also means these three hot spots need
to be at four seven coming back into 3D
once again we can see that four seven
has been created now that we've gone
ahead and adjusted all of these nodes to
suit the levels in regarding our actual
building we can go ahead and press OK
when we come back into site we then want
to select our actual site go into
massing insight and go split surface
this is going to open up a new toolbar
and Tool palette once we select on that
site again what we want to do is
actually draw around our building in its
entirety because we don't want to see
any of that Earth inside of our building
we don't have to draw around this spline
line we can simply pick lines and click
around at the edge of our pool once
we've finished our full lap around the
house we can come in and press OK and it
will split our surfaces so if we come
back into 3D you'll see that whole
surface is still there but we can select
it tap the delete button and hide our
building perfectly inside of the earth
prior to finishing off this model
there's only one thing left for us to do
and that is create a slab for the ground
floor plan a slab to the pool and then
take this model into twin motion render
out a beautiful image so that we can
showcase our best work yet
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed the video if you did make
sure you check out the playlist inside
of me for more great architectural
content if you love the video make sure
you smash the Subscribe button down
below and if you want to see more Revit
content leave a comment down below and
I'll make sure to make more of this
content for you but like always I'll see
you next Monday